nadège après cette énième conseil de
défense sanitaire est ce qu'on en sait
un peu plus sur ce qui attend les
français
ce conseil de défense ans est devenu le
rituel du mercredi pour l'exécutif pad
annonce majeure à l'issue de ce nouveau
rendez vous les autorités disent comme
depuis le début de la semaine attendre
de connaître d'abord les effets du
couvre-feu à 18 heures instaurée partout
en france depuis une dizaine de jours
pour pouvoir se prononcer des effets qui
devrait être visible à partir de samedi
mais les indicateurs sont au rouge en
croire le porte parole du gouvernement
d'après gabriel attal le couvre-feu à
18h à une efficacité relative et ne
freine pas suffisamment la propagation
du virus et donc plusieurs scénarios
serait donc envisager ce sont plusieurs
scénarios qui vont d'un maintien du
cadre actuel avec le couvre-feu à 18h
jusqu'à un confinement très serré ces
différents scénarios ont été abordés ce
matin et je rappelle que le président de
la république a demandé au gouvernement
des analyses complémentaires
épidémiologique et scientifique sur
chacun de ces scénarios et que dans le
même temps des concertations vont être
menées par le premier ministre à la
demande du président de la république
avec le comité de liaison parlementaires
les groupes parlementaires représentés
au parlement avec les partenaires
sociaux et les associations d'élus c'est
concertation approfondie vont se
dérouler dans les tout prochains jours
tian du couvre-feu ou troisième
confinement n'en sait pas vraiment plus
pour le moment ce que l'on sait elle
sait qu emmanuel macron souhaite éviter
leur confinement pourquoi parce que le
président de la république sait qu'il
joue gros politiquement et pas sûr que
les français se soumettent une nouvelle
fois d'ailleurs le phénomène de
désobéissance civile inquiète aux plus
hautes sphères de l'état
il y un phénomène de lassitude de doute
de questionnement et tout ça est
légitime et dans la décision politique
vous devez prendre en compte
l'acceptation sociale
on est sur un terrain glissant
risque en refermant le pays c'est la
désobéissance civile de certains ce soir
un nouveau dîner de travail devait avoir
lieu à l'elysée avec emmanuel macron
jean castex le premier ministre et tous
les responsables de la majorité
l om et modem un dîner de travail qui a
finalement été annulée à la dernière
minute pour éviter toute polémique
autour du non respect du couvre-feu à
18h ou des gestes barrières demain
olivier vers on doit tenir une
conférence de presse il devrait s'agir
d'un simple bilan sanitaire hebdomadaire
comme était habitué à le faire le
ministre de la santé en 2020
sauf coup de théâtre il ne devrait donc
pas y avoir d'annoncé majeure cette
semaine merci nadège abderrazak pour
toutes ces précisions en direct du
palais présidentiel à paris